mardi sur côté de réunion
salut marronnier comme le bourgeois
alexandre mallet pas reparler dans les
quatre coins de l'île pour rencontrer
les guînes unis pour voir avec eux
comment les aides du département les
soutiennent et ou réparer content et
paraît maroni pressé d'aller rencontrer
des réunionnais qui bénéficient des
aides du département elle donnera parce
que ces années sont nombreuses
qu'ils soient jeunes ou seniors
la population réunionnaise est concerné
par le dispositif dette du département
alors soyez au rendez-vous tous les
mardis à 18h40 pour votre émission le
département des générations à retrouver
sur mon telle réunion
[Musique]